so I'm gonna be talking about embracing
monolith specifically in small team so I
think there's a lot to learn in working
in small teams even if you don't really
work in a small team so it's gonna be
more of a philosophical talk and like
how to approach some sort of problems
but there's gonna be some code in both
just to show a little bit so a little
bit about me I work your eye science I
started the company about four years ago
and we do sleep coaching for elite
athletes so we we our team so teams NFL
teams pro sports teams they bring us on
board to help their athletes improve
their sleep
so everyone know sleep helps you perform
better that's sort of like there's a lot
of research to do that but no one really
knows how to help people sleep better
so obviously athletes are super
concerned about their performance and
they want to do everything they can to
sort of like be better and sleep is one
like fundamental aspect of that so they
sort of like bringers in to help their
players in a way sleep better and a
little context of sort of how we
actually work is that we go into a team
we give everyone a sleep sensor goes
onto your mattress we and we don't make
the sensor it's like an optical sensor
and then we actually gathered a lot of
subjective data about what kind of
sleeper you are and what your behaviors
are and then through that we basically
get sleep data every single day and
slowly develop a recommendation system
for you to give you a plan that's slowly
gonna get you to sleep better over time
and we do a lot of there's also like
human in the loop because obviously we
try to automate most things but sleep is
so personal and we deal with so
high-touch users that often we need to
have like a human expert involved in the
system but everything is delivered
through our mobile app and through the
system we've shown through some
experimental studies that people sleep
about 54 minutes more
on average when they use our our system
so it's a lot of sleep science and
behavioral science and not a lot of like
hardcore machine learning it's more
about applying what we know about sub
science and behavioral science and how
to slowly help people improve so we sort
of have like two main protocols I like
to think about it this way we're in one
side of things it's about sleep
improvement both objectively can we get
people to sleep longer because we know
it generally sleeping longer is better
and then subjectively the people feel
better after sleeping do they feel
there's getting more rest
do they feel less tired over time and
then user enjoyment right our product is
through an app and at the end of the day
we want them to keep coming because
that's like the main way we can
determine whether they sort of like
enjoy using the product and we need to
iterate fast so I said our company's
about four years old
we've been full-time about a year and a
half ago the three of us and our four so
we're a very small team and we measure
sort of our progress like long term is
month but usually we're talking about
weeks and even days at a time so speed
is something that's very important to us
because that's a young company we need
to be proving our product and that's it
there's an interesting aspect there
being sort of in a very young company
where you're often selling something
that you don't have but you know you can
build it so when you're sort of like
making a commitment about something you
can do you need to be able to actually
deliver that in time so data its core to
a product so I do I like to think about
to sort of companies where one and you
sort of have companies that data
enhances the product so think about
e-commerce
a lot of e-commerce companies you know
they're selling t-shirts there's a lot
of value in selling t-shirts and people
use gonna go for that to sell t-shirts
but they can use data to make that
better they can you know the usual
recommendation engine to recommend you
better teachers that are
personalized for you so that's sort of
an example that if you take the data
sort of system out of it the product
still works then you have other
companies like us where data is sort of
like these centerpiece of the product
and without data sort of like there's
nothing to do so that's a screenshot of
our app when there's no data so sort of
like it's pretty lonely there's nothing
to see you see no data you see no
recommendations yeah so sort of like
data needs to be there and it needs to
be fresh every single day that data
that's actually matters so you've been
relevant to why you're gonna do that day
so how do we actually develop the
product so to understand sort of like
why I really like this monolith
architecture it's important to
understand how developing product works
because I've been are they your so like
developing something and working through
like a process and you need to make sure
your tools are sort of adapted to the
process so usually things start with a
hypothesis right so Springs from domain
knowledge you know us being experts
about sleep or us talking to experts
about sports science and how both match
or it can be as simple as talking to
users right like why do they want to see
what would you know what kind of new
things I want to do and it can be as big
a sort of like a new you know a new
version of the app and you feature or it
can be as small as hey we want to
improve the data quality by 5% to make
sure that there are some edge cases and
we get those right usually then there's
some exploration right you have some
datasets available maybe you can collect
a little data you can talk to some users
and you sort of want your tools to help
you explore before you actually get into
the experiment phase where you try to
come up with solutions try different
ways and very cheap methods to try to
see whether there's potential in this
solution and then after that sort of
succeeds you get to a point where okay
let's actually prioritize it and make it
part of the product now you sort of need
a lot more automation a lot more
reliability in your system
now it's gonna be sort of a you know
standalone part of the product and then
after that you sort of need to keep
going and you need to evaluate what you
did often times you need to make reports
from that you need to analyze how people
are using your product where it's
falling short and so on and then ideally
after you do that that's sort of after
you keep evaluating and analyzing why
you already shipped you can then bring
that all those ideas back to generate
more like hypothesis of new steps to
work on so it sounds easy it's sort of
like a very linear linear path ideally
but then in practice sort of like it
just doesn't work that way where you get
into a roadblock and sort of like you're
stuck because you don't have data or you
can have you know access to things so
you can spend months sort of like
running experiments and you fail or you
try to prioritize things and it doesn't
really work the way you expected it to
so there's a lot of obstacles in sort of
like getting from this idea oh it's so
awesome let's make this feature to
actually getting it out there so I want
to go over a few of those data silos
where nowadays where there's a huge move
to the cloud and sort of like using
third-party solutions you sort of have
data in scattered everywhere right so
even as a small company we have data
internally that can be scattered even if
it's in the same database and then you
have data in a bunch of all they're like
third party solutions right your
customer service product you're texting
product your sales and marketing product
right so you have data in all these
separate places and oftentimes we're
trying to ask a simple question you
realize they need to spend a week sort
of like getting the data together right
few weeks ago we wanted to know whether
people that have better data quality
coming from their sensor are more likely
to use a certain feature that sounds
like a perfectly like simple question
that you for sure want to be able to
answer it right like there's this thing
that is a core data make people use this
feature more but I had
spend like a full day sort of like
getting data from Mixpanel
which is our user analytics platform and
then sort of like joining that in python
role in Python world with like our
actual like data quality metrics right
so it's sort of like anything we think
you need to do very specific sort of
like solutions because your data isn't
point to different places
you also have problems of different
tooling right as we move from
exploration into more like prototyping
things your tooling often changes right
how many of you here like start working
with like R and then sort of have to
move into the Python or Scala when
you're confident that that's a solution
you want ago right that's a pretty
common approach and often times you end
up repeating yourself okay you do this
quick thing in our it seems to work but
you were pulling it off of CSV and now
when you need to prioritize it you're
sort of like you need to talk to a
database you actually need like actual
latency concerns that you cannot wait 10
seconds to read the CSV because it needs
to be under you know 500 milliseconds
latency so you sort of like as you move
towards the probe there let me cycle you
need to change your tooling and there's
a lot of overhead in doing that then you
have people right we'll work with people
because you can really achieve great
things without great people and often
times different people on different
parts of the system and you need people
have different opinions so you spend a
lot of time as you move towards some
steps like maybe there's people that are
focused on the exploration phase and
then there's people focus on the
implementation phase right oftentimes
you see like the data science team come
up with the models and then the software
engineering team has to sort of
implement that so you have that
disconnect there which cost us a lot of
just overhead and communication really
I'm gonna talk a little more about that
and then the most fun of all the
problems I find through the programming
cycle is when you sort of have something
working it works locally it works in
staging life is great you're super
excited about this new fake sneeze new
feature and
you throw it on production and you get
alerts at 2:00 a.m. that something is
broken right that's just a feeling that
really sucks as you wake up and you're
like wait it worked perfectly everywhere
and now it doesn't work we're an
institute and there's a lot of reasons
why that can happen here's a few one so
I come from a software background and
there's this fuzzy and warm feeling
around testing software that I really
like where if something is really
important you can actually do that
comprehensive testing I ran like all
possible scenarios and know that your
software is sort of like ripe with data
products often your code is perfectly
right then why did is actually work but
oftentimes it's sort of like a box that
expects there has some assumptions and
then in production something might
change and then if you change data for
example garbage in garbage out if you
depend on a third-party data provider
like we do and they you know you have an
assumption that for the past four years
they've done the same the same like
sample frequency for time series and
then they decide to like change that
overnight without letting you know then
your hope your whole modeling system
might break and then whatever you did
now is going to be different because
they change the underlying data so
oftentimes you have sort of this these
things that are out of your control
because you cannot really know all the
assumptions of the system so testing
data products often becomes really hard
because you don't really understand all
the data can potentially come into the
system and then you have the usual
capacity problems where somehow making
things from state into production and
doing 10x the capacity now actually
creates some like weird side effects in
your like modeling and everything takes
way longer which breaks the whole
pipeline system fun things and all these
problems sort of cause you to delay and
extend the product cycle like getting
from idea to actually shipping and
evaluating the product that's gonna take
longer and that's what you should be
actually making shorter and shorter
so how do we start how do we sort of
like fix that problem obviously we betta
stop the first step is you want to do
something before you get to know and
before you get into any model and you
want to do more descriptive some visual
plotting just understanding why you're
dealing with that's usually like the
common approach but often I find that
it's important to like step back a
little bit and before getting into that
writing code and looking at the data and
looking at charts and distributions it's
important to understand what the
organization actually needs what's the
problem that we're trying to solve
what's a higher level motivation behind
the problem before focusing on the
solution which is oh I need to like look
at the data and find descriptive
statistics it's real part of your team's
and understanding like what's driving me
and why people ask me to do something
it's super important and so you can find
sort of like other things that you were
not asked for and I think the reason
behind actually stepping back and how I
find that so important is that when we
start with the solution first the focus
is on the tech trade-off right you
already want to do something and you try
you have a few ideas about to do it so
now you start debating whether you want
to use this tool or that tool we're
gonna use our Python or should I do it
in a different language or the witch
library that I wanna use so you focus on
the tech trade-off when you start with
the problem first you sort of like have
the idea of how do I make progress
towards solving the problem which should
be what we're working here right we're
trying to solve the problem we don't
necessarily have a nice in fact a
solution that doesn't really solve the
real problem so as a co-founder and also
the lead developer of a company one of
the biggest struggles is that I need to
balance sort of like the business values
and the business objective with the
technical things that we're doing right
so oftentimes I want to do this a super
fancy solution that I know is
technically
a better approach but I need to say hold
on I'm the co-founder like the business
doesn't really need that solution yet it
might be too early you might do it's not
so we were not so sure that we need that
long term so why impasse and sort of
like developing that structure so as you
sort of like getting to more technical
solutions and you try to get more and
more optimality in your technical stack
and your tech stack you actually sort of
you might end up decreasing your
business value because you might you
know you may want to do something that's
100 milliseconds of latency and then to
do that you need to like invest in a lot
of complexity to make that fast enough
which means that later on their own
later down the road for the business if
you want to change something it's harder
so now why you did which was a better
technical approach you did something
faster may your business harder to
change which is one of our goals we need
to be able to change the product fast I
like I love this quote by Jason free on
so when you say no to one thing you're
just saying no to that specific thing
when when you agree to something you're
sort of like saying no to everything
else and I think that applies perfectly
here when we want to do really good at a
technical point like making this thing
super fast or super accurate we're
offering sacrificing some other things
like not spending time doing some other
thing so I usually start with sort of
like that question what's the least I
can do to solve the problem sometimes I
feel like I'm just too lazy and I'm
succeeding that my computer like am I
really thinking this like I don't want
to work or what but I find this super
helpful because personally and I know a
lot of my friends in software and data
sort of like we like using new tools we
like fancy things so oftentimes all we
need is like a good excuse to try this
new library and this new algorithm
because why not why not try that then
why not try tensorflow if you're trying
to do something why not try SPARC if
it's really cool and people like it it's
shiny like I want to play with it so why
not do it this solution that doesn't
really need that but I just want to use
it so I think it helps me asking these
questions sort of like
puts the question in in my mind and
helps me counter my bias against sort of
like using new and fancy tools used for
the sake of checking them out so we need
an architecture and we need a set of
tools and frameworks that are compatible
with how we want operate and how we
wanna like approach the problem so
here's the here's where the monolithic
architecture comes in so from the
software world and in 2016 this is a lot
of people I'll be debating about it I
like a lot of the work from Martin
Fowler he's a great thinker on software
practices and he describes the
monolithic application as one where like
all the moving parts are in just one
process right so you got that box and
you have the red circle the green little
triangle and like these are all
functionality and they're all in one
process and literally one the code base
and then when you need to like to scale
up when you need to do more of that all
you do is copy that same thing in
multiple servers and that's how you sort
of get scale whereas the micro-services
approach you sort of like break every
single piece of functionality into their
own into their own services that are
fully isolated independent and when you
need to scale you can use make
mix-and-match whatever you need so you
can put two of these little services in
that server and then two of those three
of those services in that other server
and sort of like if you need more of the
of the login authentication service you
can just spin up more of those services
and you can have a whole team inside
your company manage one service so you
didn't really get a lot of you don't
need to like coordinate with every
single other team when you're doing
something so here's a great chart and
sort of like the trade-off between two
approaches on the x-axis you sort of
have the base complexity of operating
something of your code base of your
product and then on the y-axis you have
your productivity of your team of your
company right the Green Line is the
monolith where you start off and you're
very productive right because everything
is
in one codebase every single thing you
sort of know how it works you can put it
in your head you can look up the code in
one sort of everything's in one place
everything can talk to each other much
more easily but as you sort of move to
the right and your thing gets way more
complex way more moving parts then your
productivity sort of like drops
drastically because now every little
change you need to make sure that it's
sort of like doesn't break the whole
world and it's touching a lot of parts
so that's dangerous so as you get more
complex you sort of get more risk-averse
and you don't really want to touch
things because it's you know what side
effects are on the other end sort of on
the micro-service the blue line you
start right off the bat you're less
productive Ryker's from this you know
you sort of have ten services you need
the log in thing you need the predictive
model thing you need the data ingestion
service you need the login server so all
these services and just to make them
talk to each other there's a lot of
overhead right usually you have one team
or set of people manage one service so
just to get like a new thing you need to
coordinate between a whole set of teams
and it's not all in one place but as you
get more and more complex of your of
your product then making chain when you
own one service making changes to that
service is much easier because you don't
really depend on everything else you can
just make changes and you know sort of
like what contract you have with other
people and with other teams and with
other services and that's you can be
more confident that you're not gonna
like break the whole world by making a
little change so over time as
organizations get more complex doing
micro services is often the right
approach right because you grow too big
that there's no way you can sort of
manage everything into one monolith
there's a few exceptions but a lot of
big companies have moved towards a micro
service kind of approach so django
django is a who's familiar with django
here it's a web framework okay great a
lot of people so it's a web frame where
he makes doing a lot of things that web
that require like web needs super easy
like having a server having API having
sort of like forms and valuation and
logging and all of these things that
every
NEADS it's put in one place it's
probably the biggest Django a Python web
framework and the reason I like it is
that it has a lot of built-in tools that
I don't really have to worry about so
I'm going to go to a little bit of those
so besides the building tools it's super
important to be like reuse libraries
that are out there right that Tweety's
was great so the hardest problem in
computer science is fighting the urge to
solve a different more interesting
problem than they want a hand
how often like I'm working on a problem
there's this great library that does 60%
of the job and I'm like wait I want to
do this library better because I can and
I have this specific set of needs so why
not just do it myself
right it's a fun challenge so you sort
of want to work on these like bigger
more complicated problems and you can
sort of like sidestep from while you're
actually trying to solve so in Django
you can integrate super easily with your
ipython set of notebooks right so do we
manage a pie that sort of like the
Django utility to like do anything
anything Django related he has all the
scripts in there and you can spin off a
notebook ipython notebook which simply
that command and then you sort of like
bring up a whole environment where where
you have your whole production code your
whole stack that you are already using
for sort of like moving data around and
validating beta and you can use that for
exploring data from like the data side
from the data science side of things so
one of the funny things that we love
that beta community we love complaining
about how much time we spend like
cleaning and wrangling data right we
spend all this time cleaning the air
getting it the right place and then like
one percent of the time is actually
running the fonts of the models what
happens that's sort of in the software
world it's about the same right you
spend all this time like validating data
making sure that the form data that you
get from API is correct making sure that
that day times are formatted properly so
making sure that the user IDs are
formatted so all of these things you
spent all this time valuating and
wrangling data from the software side so
when you subpoena up and you try to do
sort of like the data science tack and
you have access to your production
application setup and code base you can
stuff like you reuse a lot of the
tooling so it's really cool when you can
start doing some exploration and you can
just use the same code that already is
in production to sort of like get that
data and clean it for you so you sort of
get that for free by by being all in
your one code base the ORM so the ORM is
the part that matches sort of like maps
the data base to your Python objects so
when you're sort of developing software
you want to have these like nice little
objects that contain your date and you
can like tell them to do things and ask
questions to those objects right so for
example we have a big table in our
database that holds all the sleep data
for people and that table you know it's
big it has a lot of interesting so like
computations that we can do on that
table so all the time we're just like
piping data from that table to we want
to do something with that in the data
science side of things so early on we
would usually just dump did they tend to
see as V's pipe it into like loaded in
our and do everything in our but then
slowly realize wait I can just load this
up on through Python and I can ask it a
question and start working on the same
data science stack inside my jungle code
base inside ipython because I basically
get very similar tooling that I get in R
so for people that don't really know the
jungle query language well it's
basically all I'm doing saying sleep
that's my table get me everything but
that matches that filter and that filter
is for the person ID one which is
becoming my ID and has a sleeping date
that's greater than or equals that's a
double underscore August August first
right so that double underscore is
actually a really great feature of
Django I don't know how many of you know
like actually on how to query Django
he basically allows you to do is like
arbitrary joins and operations on your
queries that are fully dynamic right so
I have this sleeping date that column
and I can just do double underscore and
tell it greater than and it's just gonna
basically translate that into that
sequel query to my posters and he's just
gonna select all the columns from my
sleep that I need where the person is
one and the sleeping date is more than
you know it's later than August first so
that's sort of like does that for you so
you can use all your production queries
I already have in Python to pull data
into your like data science and
exploration phase there's a few tool
obviously patents is great when you're
doing data moving around and you want to
model stuff so there's a few ways of
doing it my preferred way is the Django
pandas library which is really a thin
wrapper around pulling data from the
database from Django into pandas so you
can tell things like just read frame and
it's going to automatically get go to
that query pull data from the database
and just get that into a panda's data
frame and do all the right conversions
for you so it's sort of like super easy
in one line you're getting from you're
asking the thing to give you to do a
query for you do all the conversion into
Python and pandas right you don't have
to worry about getting data from the
database into like a nice usable pandas
frame and for example in this case I
want to get they I want to find how much
I'm sleeping by day of week right a
reasonable question that one time I
actually wanted to know for for part of
a product and I can probably write that
in sequel I can maybe get the full table
and then do the whole thing in pandas
but I you sort of like combining both
you can mix and match what things are
sequel is good for what things Python
are good for and what things you so like
need to just write some manual scripts
so you know with this super simple
example I'm just like in three lines I'm
sort of like getting the data from the
database through my Python query through
my Python back-end code and getting into
something that I want another benefit of
the interim
patien no benefit of the monolith is
that we sort of have instrumentation
sort of for free like I'm already doing
instrumentation for my back-end code so
I can use the same tooling to sort of
like know how my data science stack is
performing right this was a few days ago
when we rolled out a new model and the
latency that model went super high
because it was way more intensive
computation right I didn't really have
to do anything because my back-end was
also already tracking sort of like oh
the oh my system right so I sort of get
that for free by integrating everything
one code base so I want to talk a little
bit about the people and how that sort
of I create challenges in the product
cycle so there's this idea that I read
in a great book by some Google engineers
I forget to put a quote here but how
coil which is like a very mechanical
repetitive tasks that are often boring
can create sort of like a negative
culture right
you have people non-technical people
that want data so they ask engineers of
the data team and that's what like takes
time because engineers are busy doing
something else so people slowly stop
asking data because they feel bad about
asking the engineers and wasting their
time so over time user role evolved into
a culture where people don't want ask
data because they feel bad about what
other engineers or it takes too long so
I think one of the main ways of sort of
like bridging that gap is by trying to
move towards like a self-serve analytics
where everyone in the team in the
company is in power to get access to the
data and answer their own questions so
one of the main ways of getting there
the first step is sort of like breaking
the data silos right getting all the
data that I was talking about in warm
place and centralizing it so for the
sake of time I'm gonna skip this slide
but centralizing data a super important
if you want to be able to sort of like
give self-serve analytics to all your
people for in our case we sort of like
pipe all the customer data from like app
usage and client-side analytics through
segments which basically aggregates
everything for us and that they dump it
into a database for us we also
our back-end server and then through a
super simple company called stitch they
basically just copy over all these data
sources and pipe it into redshift it's
literally like a one-click setup I don't
have to do anything and I have like a
super nice production copy of all my
client and Alixe and back-end data into
like a redshift so I can actually query
and run dashboards again against so why
is that awesome because I basically get
it for free because redshift is
basically Postgres or at least it has
the same interface so I can run a query
like this which I'm aggravated a lot
like a huge table of over 100 million
rows to find the average heart rate of a
of a team of a team right so in posters
that took that takes over 200 seconds
whereas in redshift that was super quick
in four seconds so by getting that sort
of like difference in time you sort of
like give yourself a chance to ask B
your question so you don't have to wait
too long right when you have to wait 200
seconds you sort of don't really want to
do it because you don't want a context
switch and wait for the thing to finish
and the great thing is that it's almost
compatible with Postgres out-of-the-box
right so you can basically use the exact
same django code i already have and just
switch the underlying database to point
it to redshift and run the same back-end
that's now for like analytical queries
it's gonna be much much faster in this
case there is like a one little change
in the code but usually you do that in
the config so you don't even have to do
any code changes and it mostly works
there's some little problems especially
of using like suppose your specific data
types but generally it's pretty good
the last point I want to make is about
bringing data to the people we're
obviously working with people and
oftentimes they have to go to different
places to get data they have to go to
Mixpanel to run queries they have to go
to our admin page to like figure out
some data stuff so I find it's super
helpful to bring data to a people and
bring it to where they are so obviously
we're heavy users of slack and we sort
of like end up piping everything into
slack and make it
super-easy so slack makes it really
simple to do right custom integrations
so for example we did something that
anyone in the company can do slash
report and put the report name that they
want and our back and you're just gonna
pipe it into slack it takes literally
tens I lines of code in Django to do
that and it gives all the non-technical
people a lot of power in just getting
this report whenever they want on their
phones or under computers right so you
don't have to sort of like do a complex
solution you can just bring it super
easy to where they are you can also push
data to the people right you don't have
to wait until people one data to give it
to them if you know someone is in charge
of the customer service and they're sort
of like a net we have a lot of problems
with Wi-Fi as well since our sensors
connected wirelessly check out the
sensor it's not connecting right instead
of waiting for that person to sort of
like decide to open up the monitoring
dashboard for Wi-Fi terrors so I sort of
like creates that positive feedback loop
that people are encouraged encouraged to
ask more and more questions because they
have access to today yeah and they don't
feel bad about bothering the engineering
or data team about wasting their time
and that way the engineering data team
can then focus on getting better and
better tools for the people to get their
own data and obviously it's hard it's
like an ambitious goal and often it's
hard to get there but we should strive
into making it a self-serve as much as
we can
the last point I want to make is sort of
like be scrappy and Python is the
awesome language a lot of libraries to
be scrappy and often you don't need that
super fancy new thing to do it when you
can just maybe spin up at bigger AWS ec2
machine that has 200 gigabytes of RAM
and quickly run an experiment right that
might be way quicker and way cheaper
than spinning spinning up a Hadoop
cluster in SPARC so oftentimes being
scrapping and having that mindset gets
you there much faster and helps your
team thanks
any questions if we have time yeah yeah
so in monolith argue the main thing for
us is that we're a small team we don't
need the complexity of a service because
when you're in service you sort of have
a lot more complexity in managing and
orchestrating all these independent
service to talk to each other right just
keeping them talking to a subversion and
making the deployment strategy work at
that point is a huge pain right I talk
to my friends in big companies and when
they're at that point where there's a
lot more moving parts it's absolutely
make sense and it would be the wrong
decision to do a monolith but in our
case we're a small team we understand
where we are and that's we're sort of
like using this monolith that everyone
sort of like understands the whole
system yes it puts a lot more pressure
in people because they need to
understand the system but they also take
more care of the system because now
they're going to be touching every part
and they know everyone else is going to
be touching the whole system so they
sort of like need to put effort into
keeping the system nice and tidy so that
make sense yeah I mean just pinning up
those things often take a lot of time
and it absolutely makes sense I think
one of the things that the monolith gets
like a bad rap is that it makes it super
easy and I hate in theory I don't think
there's a fundamental problem but in
practice it makes it super easy to sort
of like cross your boundaries and write
crappy code by touching part and but not
by not tipping modular whereas in micro
services you don't even have access to
the other like classes in your system so
you have to you're forced to keep it
modular whereas in the monolith you sort
of have to be much more self-discipline
and say hold on this is getting this
class these objects shouldn't really be
talking to that object even though it's
in the same
codebase and I can import it so I think
that's a problem it brings a lot of the
of the discipline into developers in
saying no I'm going to respect the the
modularity of my code and keep it clean
yeah I mean that's a great question yeah
so the question is that we're a small
company and as we grow it probably is
going to make sense to switch to a
services architecture because as I said
bigger teams usually benefit from
services so the question is how do I
think about you know starting as a
monolith and then deciding when the
switching cost is gonna be better
is it going to be worth it to transition
over so the quick answer is that I
that's a question that we have because
obviously has to invest more and more in
the monolith sort of like it makes the
switching cost higher and higher but
since we're a small company most of the
code I've written
actually we sort of like don't even use
anymore right because we're always
iterating on the product doing the
features trying new things so I think
part of the answer is that as you sort
of grow enough you sort of can identify
like a few key parts of your system that
are you know maybe really high load and
maybe those are the few things that you
can start taking our systems abstracting
out extracting out and then you sort of
evaluate how that process works and
slowly start taking pieces out into
services instead of sort of like saying
I'm going to rewrite the whole thing
from scratch and services so that's my
approach and I actually started doing a
little bit of that our predictive model
that we use is actually an independent
service that it's still in the same code
base but it's managed by like a whole
different deployment setup so even
though it's the same codebase and I can
use
kote is sort of like deploy and to
different plays and has a different you
know over stations set up yeah yeah
Yushu so that's where we actually have
to build it so the question is I show
you how people can through slack just
get a quick report that they want to do
right the customer service people can
get you know the customer engagement
data right there in slack so how does do
how do they actually look they're
basically like a table of text sometimes
you can pipe in through I pythons and
you having your code base you can
generate an image and just pipe it
through slack so you can actually send a
chart of engagement data through slack
there is quite a bit of like manual
working getting that the reports going
you know like actually formatting it
properly and you still need to actually
get the queries but often times those
queries that you need for reports you
already have sort of for your production
data so you're just moving that around
and doing the right formatting so most
of the time for us it's just literally
text and like names of customers that
customer service needs to interact with
any other questions thanks for coming
share it